저희 스터디는 2016년도 9월 달에
시작을 해서 수강생이 약 1천명 정도
되고요 그중에 건물주가 되신 분들이
약 200명 정도 됩니다 시부터
시까지 어 3시간을 진행할 예정이고
2주차부터 5주 차까지는 강의 시작
전에 어 답사까지 진행할 예정입니다
빌딩 투자할 때 저는 제일 중요하게
생각하는게 저와 같은 이제 중개사
그리고 운행 지점장 그리고
건축사님이라고 제가 항상 말씀드리는데
그런 팀을 만들어 드릴 겁니다 저희
강의의 치지는 그런 팀을 만들어
드리고 수강생들끼리 네트워크를 만들어
드리기 위해서이 스터디를 처음 시작을
했습니다 정말 준비를 많이 했고
그동안 쌓여 있던 그런 노하우들이
그지 이런게 너무 많기 때문에 앞으로
빌딩 투자의 계획이 있으신 분들은
들으시면 굉장히 큰 도움이 될 거라고
저는 확신을 합니다네 그리고 저도
1주 차와 5주차를 강의를 하니까 어
많은 기대를 해 주셔도 좋을 것
같습니다 어 빌딩 투자에 대한 기본
개념 중에 용어 정리나 여러분들이
평소에 좀 헷갈리셨던 부분에 대해서
명확하게 좀 알게 되실 수 있고
아무래도 이제 저 같은 경우 이제
실무진에 담당하고 있기 때문에 가장
궁금해하시는 뭐 빌딩 시장 동향이나
가장 최근의 거래된 사례 같은 경우도
저희가 직접 설명드리는 경우가
많습니다 1딩 메이비 고민이시라면
지금 바로 신청하십시오 제소에 잠깐
해드리면 저는 이제 17년 4기부터
빌 스터디에서 이제 부동산 관련 법인
설립 이제 강의하고 있고요 이제 벌써
23년 있데 한 만년 정도 지난 거
같습니다 제 강의에서는 어 부동산
세금에 대한 이야기는 아니에요 부동산
법인의 설립 그리고 운영 그리고 살짝
세금 그리고 마지막에는 뭐 요새 가장
이슈죠 부실 지문 기업 뭐 제문제 표
그래서 어 단순히 세금 강의가 아니다
그리고 부동산 법인의 정말 설립부터
운영 전과정에 대한 이야기를 제가
들려 드릴 예정입니다 네이버 같은 거
지지 마시고 여기 오셔서 세미나 한번
들으시면 될 것 같습니다 꼬마비 등의
앱비 건축주가 되기 위한 첫걸음 저희
bsn 건설이 도와드립니다 건물 하나
짓는데 10년 늙는다는 말 들어보셨죠
그만큼 시공하는데 사전 준비 없이는
정말 힘듭니다 저희 bsm 스터디에서
제공하는 강의를 들어보신다면 신축
리모델링을 하는데 이미 절반 이상의
성공을 거두신 것입니다 건축주분들은
기본적으로 알아두셔야 할 법규 그리고
시공 계약부터 공 지 시공에 관련된
어까지 꼭 필요한 정를 낱낱이
말씀드리겠습니다 저희 스터디에서는
건축 설계가 진행되는 전 과정에 대해
알려 드리고 있습니다 건축 설계는
단계별로 진행되는 사항들이 다르기
때문에 그런 부분들을 어떻게 진행해야
되는지 좀 상세하게 말씀드리고 있으며
신축과 리모델링이 또 다른 점들이
있기 때문에 어 각각의 개발 용도에
따른 그런 설계 과정들을 상세하게
말씀드리고 있습니다 그리고 저희가
설계하고 있는 프로젝트들의 사례를
통해서 실제 건물이 어떻게 지어지는지
그 과정을 직접 보실 수 있도록
저희가 공사하고 있는 현장을 방문해서
답사하는 그런 기회도 같이 제공해
드리고 있습니다 저희 스터디를 통해서
건축주로서 경험을 미리 해보시는 좋은
기회가 될 거
같습니다 아주 5주 동안 많은 걸
배울 수
있었고 지금 장은 아니지만 앞으로 건
다라는 느낌을 확실히
봤고 유익한 수업이었습니다 처음에
왔을 때는이 어떤 건물을 보는 시점
시각이라 이런 지식들이 전혀 없었는데
강의를 오직 끝나서 보니까 이제
나름대로 많은 지식을 좀 얻어 간 거
같고요 제가 앞으로도 이렇게 건물 살
때 어떤 부분을 봐야 하는지 어떤
부분을 체크해야 되는지에 대해서
대략적인 것들 좀 알 수 있는 좋은
기회였던 거 같습니다이 기회를 통해서
저도 이제 건물주가 될 수 있다는
자신감을 좀 가질수 있던 같 부동산
공부라는 기이 상당히 좀 막연하고
너무 광범위하고 특히나 이제 빌딩
스터디라는 거는 더 막연했는데
유용하고 실질적인 사례들을 많이
말씀해 주시니까 훨씬 더 그런 개념이
좀 생겼다는 굉장히 도움이 되었던 거
같고요 답사하면서 굉장히 좀 재미가
있었는데요 보통은 이제 사람들 많은
곳들 이제 갈 때 그냥 핫플레
있으니까 가고 이런 거 정도였던 거
같은데 아 왜이 상권이 좋고 이런
데에 대한 이런 곳에 있는 빌딩의
가치들을 좀 생각을 해보는 이런
기회를 가졌다는게 굉장히 좀 도움이
많이 된 거 같습니다 실용적이고
재밌는 당했습니다 감사합니다에 여기
비스 교육을 했다는 걸 알게 되서
참가를 했는데 결과는 대만족이었습니다
보통 투자 강세에 소개돼 있는 그런
내용뿐만 아니라 강산과 그리고
손의 실경을 토대로 살아있는 강 듣게
돼 가지고 투자할 수 있는데 살아있는
시를 습득하는 거 제일 좋았습니다
다른 분들한테도 강입니다 꼭 드리시기
바랍니다